la parole est à notre collègue gilbert
roger pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain sur le sénateur monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre ma
question s'adresse à monsieur laurent
nunez
monsieur le ministre je tiens tout
d'abord à en préambule à ma question a
condamné fermement toutes les violences
commises à l'égard des forces de l'ordre
qui ont émaillé certaines des
manifestations des filets jaunes depuis
le mois de novembre
la condamnation de ces agissements ne
peut cependant faire oublier le grand
nombre de manifestants blessés par les
lanceurs de balles de défense lbd près
d'une centaine de blessés graves ont été
recensées en grand majorité par les tirs
de ces engins dont 17 ont perdu un oeil
depuis le début de la contestation
depuis 2009 le lbd40 a remplacé le
flash-ball super pro dans les opérations
de maintien de l'ordre
car plus puissant plus précis en théorie
son usage est très encadrée le tireur
doit viser de façon privilégiée le torse
ainsi que les membres supérieurs ou
inférieurs mais en aucun cas la tête
pour rappel la france en terme de
maintien de l'ordre fait figure
d'exception
elle est le seul pays européen utilisé
des grenades explosives
l'un des rares avec la grèce l'espagne
et la pologne à faire usage de l bd
votre ministère a lancé le 23 décembre
dernier un appel d'offres pour
l'acquisition de 1280 nouveau lbd
l'emploi de tir du ldd a été massif
depuis le début des mouvements des gilet
jaune par des effectifs en civil non
spécialistes des manifestations
et de l' usage de ses armes dites
intermédiaires
l'année dernière le défenseur des droits
à votre question
monsieur jacques toubon dans un rapport
brooke pardon préconise l interdiction
de l usage du lbd ma question est donc
la suivante monsieur le ministre devant
l'insuffisance de formation des à la
doctrine d'emploi de ces armes par les
forces de l'ordre et l'efficacité
contestée du dispositif de caméra
remettront le gouvernement compte-t-il
suivre l'avis du défenseur des droits en
interdisant l'usagé de ces armes
la réponse est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du louvre de l'intérieur que
laurent neige monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur roger d'abord merci
du soutien que vous venez d'apporter aux
forces de l'ordre vous en remercie
vivement
concernant l'usagé du nbd d'abord vous
rappeler monsieur le sénateur que tous
les samedis maintenant nous avons un
rendez vous dans le cadre du mouvement
dit de gilet jaune où il ya des
manifestations de voie publique qui sont
organisées partout en france à paris
comme vous le savez et puis à hyères en
province chaque samedi nous assistons au
même scène où un certain nombre
d'individus très violent des casseurs se
mêlent aux manifestations et les fonds
dégénéré parfois au début souvent à la
fin et c'était encore le cas samedi
dernier sur la place de la bastille sont
des casseurs extrêmement violent qui pis
qui s'en prennent aux forces de l'ordre
qui quand ils le peuvent s'en prennent à
nos institutions c'est à dire aux
mairies aux préfectures au
sous-préfecture de manière extrêmement
violente et pardon mais on peut parfois
difficilement qualifier ça de gestion de
maintien d'ordre public ce à quoi ce à
quoi à part dont sont confrontés nos
forces de l'ordre s'apparente beaucoup
plus à des une forme de guérilla urbaine
et nos effectifs interviennent à ce
moment là pour mettre fin à ces
exactions pour mettre fin à ces pillages
pour mettre fin à ces violences
et effectivement vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur roger à ce moment
là ils utilisent tous là
moment intermédiaires qui est à leur
disposition pour éviter justement
d'utiliser un armement létale sans
lequel il ne pourrait se défendre sans
lesquels leur intégrité physique serait
menacée et il s'agit également de
protéger le reste des manifestants qui
ne demandent pas avoir ces casseurs et
c'est ce que nous faisons tous les
samedis alors oui le lb est utilisé
c'était encore le cas samedi dernier sur
la place de la bastille sur la place de
la république
uniquement dans les moments de grande
tension et ce matériel est utilisé je
peux vous le confirmer
il est utilisé par un personnel qui est
habilité qui est formé à cette fin dans
un usage qui est proportionné qui est
contrôlé et quand il ya des fautes elles
sont sanctionnées
et quand il y a des suspicions de
violence il ya des investigations
judiciaires qui sont menées et c'est le
cas actuellement avec l'inspection
générale de la police nationale qui est
site qui est saisi un certain nombre
d'affaires mais devant vous je veux
d'abord qu'orange et un policier blessé
et penser au courage et à la
détermination de nos forces de l'ordre
qui tous les samedis font face merci
la parole est au président claude
malhuret pour le groupe des indépendants
république et territoires monsieur le
président vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier ministre le
venezuela possède les plus grandes
réserves mondiales de pétrole et son
peuple crève de faim le dictateur de
caracas emprisonné assassine 100 morts
ces jours derniers 600 prisonniers
politiques régulièrement torturé trois
millions de réfugiés plus de médicaments
en revanche pour la drogue pas de
problème le plus grand cartel de
narcotrafiquants du monde est supervisé
par les militaires vénézuéliens
eux-mêmes deux hommes se prétendent
aujourd'hui président de la république
le castro de chavistes maduro à l'issue
d'une élection truquée dénoncé dans le
monde entier et juan garrido élu lui
démocratiquement président de
l'assemblée nationale maduro ça
n'étonnera personne est soutenue par les
pays ultra démocratique que sont la
russie la chine la turquie et cuba
l'iran et la corée du nord
il est aussi soutenu à fond en france
par le leader minimo de la france
soumise à cuba qui repère les dictateurs
qui repère les dictateurs avec un flair
infaillible le tyranneau fils mélenchon
qui dénonce les violences policières à
paris mais supporte sans trop de douleur
les centaines de morts à caracas
gaye 2 est reconnue par la
quasi-totalité des pays d'amérique
latine et au total par une vingtaine de
pays du monde
l'union européenne qui penche pour gaido
s'est contenté d'appeler par ce qu'elle
appelle un ultimatum à de nouvelles
élections
hélas maduro à rejeter immédiatement cet
ultimatum ce qui n'a pour le moment
entraîné aucune réaction de l'europe un
ultimatum sans conséquence vous me
l'accorderez monsieur le premier
ministre c'est évidemment un peu fâché
trois journalistes espagnols et deux
journalistes français ont été arrêtés
hier à caracas
on est sans nouvelles d'eux l'espagne a
exigé publiquement la libération
immédiate de ces journalistes alors je
voudrais vous poser deux questions ce
premier ministre premièrement la france
et l'union européenne vont elles
reconnaître le président gaillot avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard et que la guerre
civile n'éclate au venezuela
deuxièmement le gouvernement compte-t-il
exigé publiquement la libération
immédiate des journalistes français et
avez-vous de leur nouvelle je vous
remercie
la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président malgré vous
m'interrogez sur le venezuela a de quoi
parlons nous dans cette crise terrible
que connaît ce pays nous parlons d'un
pays qui est plongé depuis plus de trois
ans dans une crise sans précédent
un pays potentiellement riche qui
connaît aujourd'hui des situation de
près et famine une économie totalement
exemple une population dont nous savons
qu'elle est privée de médicaments et de
l'ensemble des biens de première
nécessité
parlons d'un pays qui a mis en place une
répression sanglante de ces oppositions
nous parlons d'un pays vous l'avez sites
est monsieur le président qui
emprisonnent les journalistes étrangers
deux journalistes français ont été
arrêtés trois journalistes espagnols je
me permets de vous indiquer monsieur le
président malhuret que le ministre des
affaires étrangères et l'ensemble du
gouvernement a exigé la libération
immédiate de ces journalistes et de
leurs collègues et confrères espagnols
nous parlons aujourd'hui au venezuela
d'un président qui revendique un second
mandat présidentiel sur la base
d'élections qui se sont tenues en mai
2018 qui ne répondait de toute évidence
à aucune des conditions essentielles de
la démocratie aujourd'hui le venezuela
est à la croisée des chemins
depuis que le 23 janvier se sont tenues
des manifestations massives et que le
jour même le président de l'assemblée
nationale juan garrido a prêté serment
comme président par intérim du venezuela
en vue at-il affirmé
d'organiser des élections véritablement
démocratiques
notre responsabilité celle de la france
celle de l'union européenne c'est de
veiller au respect de la volonté du
peuple vénézuélien
c'est le sens de la déclaration du
président de la république qui le 26
janvier dernier a appelé à l' annonce
dans un délai de huit jours de la
convocation de nouvelles élections
à défaut monsieur le président nous
reconnaîtrons en pleine coordination
avec nos partenaires européens avec
l'allemagne
avec l'espagne avec le royaume uni juan
garrido comme président par intérim du
venezuela pour avancer en ce sens
c'est également monsieur le président
c'est également le sens de la création
d'un groupe de contact international
proposé par l'union européenne parce que
nous sommes convaincus que la seule
solution viable à cette crise est
politique négociée et pacifique avec la
coopération des organisations régionales
et des pays qui entourent le venezuela
le ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian est
aujourd'hui même à bucarest avec ses
homologues européens pour consolider et
affirmer cette position commune face à
la crise un mot peut-être sur la
situation humanitaire qui est
préoccupante
plus de 3 millions de vénézuéliens ont
quitté leur pays et l'onu estiment que
d'ici la fin de l'année cela pourrait
monter jusqu'à 5 millions et demi de
ressortissants vénézuélien qui
quitteraient leur pays si pourquoi
l'union européenne a dégagé une
enveloppe de 55 millions d'euros d' aide
humanitaire depuis 2018 je voudrais
enfin indiqué et je sais que les
sénateurs y sont particulièrement
sensibles que le gouvernement se
mobilise pour garantir la protection des
quelques 4000 ressortissants français
qui sont demeurés sur place un certain
nombre de nos ressortissants à quitter
le pays
ophir au fur et à mesure de la
dégradation de la situation mais il
reste environ 4000 nous veillons à leur
sécurité et toutes les options sont
étudiées y compris la possibilité de
rapatrier ceux qui demanderaient à
l'être si la situation devait empirer
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
à part en les maintenant au président
philippe bas pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole ma question s'adressait à madame
le garde des sceaux mais celle ci n'a
pas pu nous rejoindre nous avons une
vive préoccupation celle du service
public de la justice
le service public de la justice est en
crise le service public de la justice
est en grande souffrance
nous avons constaté que les délais de
jugement ne cesse de s'allonger
les peines sont mal exécutée les prisons
sont saturés une réforme a été engagée
pour répondre à ces difficultés
cette réforme a suscité une hostilité
sans précédent de toutes les professions
de justice
nous les avons réunis hier en tables
rondes elles attendent plus de garanties
pour les droits des justiciables
elles attendent aussi plus de garanties
que la couverture de chacun de nos
territoires sera correctement assuré le
sénat partage intégralement ses
préoccupations ils vous demandent ils
demandent au gouvernement de bien
vouloir suspendre les travaux
parlementaires pour trouver un accord
qui permettra de faire en sorte que une
réponse appropriée pertinentes et
consensuelle soit apportée aux
préoccupations du monde de la justice
partagé par nos collectivités
non la parole
les communistes en charge des relations
avec le parlement lesieu péno merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président bah je vais tout d'abord
excusé l'absence de la garde des sceaux
qui s'est rendu auprès des personnels
pénitentiaires à tarascon après
l'évasion intervenue en début de semaine
vous m'interrogez sur vous interroger le
gouvernement sur la réforme de la
justice qui est en cours aujourd'hui à
un stade avancé de la navette
parlementaire je sais que vous avez
organisé comme vous l'avez rappelé une
table ronde d'hier avec plusieurs
organisations du monde de la justice et
que vous avez également invité madame la
garde des sceaux à venir s'exprimer
devant la commission des lois ce qu'elle
a fait également hier au cours des
débats parlementaires qui se sont tenues
depuis octobre dernier on a pu observer
des points de convergence réelle autour
d'un objectif commun donner enfin à la
justice les moyens auxquels elle peut
pétant prétendre et la réforme et pour
prendre en compte les besoins des
justiciers jeu le président bah vous
annonce vous disiez à juste titre qu'il
y avait une vraie urgence sur la justice
et de ce fait je comprends moins d'une
certaine façon votre expression et à
demander finalement une pause parce
qu'il ya besoin et vous avez raison de
le dire d'une réforme profonde de la
justice qui répondent aux besoins des
justiciers ces besoins sont ceux d'une
justice de proximité qui soit efficace
et moderne qui soit plus rapide et vous
avez raison de le rappeler et qui
protège les français tout en
garantissant leurs doigts sur les moyens
d'atteindre ces objectifs le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale ont divergé votre
assemblée partie d'une position qu'elle
avait été qu'elle avait élaboré dès le
printemps 2010 cette étude ne
correspondait pas au choix à la fois
fait part le gouvernant après la
consultation organisée dans le cadre des
chantiers de la justice au cours de
l'examen par l'assemblée nationale le
texte a évolué démontrant l'ouverture du
gouvernement et de la majorité sur ce
sujet je voudrais vous rappeler que
alors que le projet initial prévoyait
une répartition des juridictions sur la
carte administrative qui est telle
qu'elle était prévue jeudi a été décidée
par le gouvernement après écoute des
élus et des professions judiciaires de
choisir le menthe de maintien du
maillage territorial de justice tel
qu'il avait été prévu si vous dire si
notre souhait constant c'est de faire en
sorte que la justice soit écoutée et que
les moyens soient donnés la réforme
arrive un stade de la navette où le
texte semble se dessiner
définitivement je ne doute pas que le
travail du sénat permettrait
certain nombre de dispositions et c'est
donc donc avec cet esprit là que nous
abordons la dernière lecture qui va se
dérouler désormais au sénat je remercie
monsieur le président bord monsieur le
ministre est de vous dire que cet esprit
est un esprit de fermeture on ne peut
pas avoir raison seul contre tout le
monde
on ne peut pas réformer la société par
voie d'autorité c'est très rare que les
greffiers les magistrats les avocats
soient tous d'accord c'est très rare
qu'une assemblée comme le sénat et
trouver des points de convergence qui
coïncide avec les attentes manifesté par
les professions de justice et je crois
que le gouvernement serait bien inspiré
après les troubles des dernières mois de
commencer à comprendre qu'une autre
méthode est préférable si on veut
réformer la société en profondeur
il faut d'abord recherché par le
dialogue davantage de consensus c'est ce
que nous vous offrons de faire en
essayant de dégager nous mêmes des
points d'accord avec les professions de
justice
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue dominique
vais rien pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole mal chers
collègues
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics chargé de la fonction publique
vous avez prévu de réduire encore les
services de la direction générale des
finances publiques pour faire des
économies on ne peut vous en vouloir
mais une fois de plus elles se feront
sur les territoires plutôt qu'à bercy
cependant dans une note préparatoire de
décembre 2018
vos services prônait la concertation
locale la recherche d'un équilibre
territorial ou encore l'utilisation de
nouveaux outils comme la téléconférence
alors chiche monsieur le ministre
osez la concertation la vraie car un
courrier d'information envoyé un élu un
mois avant l'arrêt d'un service public
n'est pas une concertation et je vous
suggère dans vos nouveaux outils
d'intégrer les maisons de services au
public
elles sont en effet les derniers relais
de l'administration en milieu rural mais
pour cela il faudrait que les
administrations acceptent de collaborer
avec ses maisons ce qui n'est
malheureusement pas toujours le cas
alors monsieur le ministre vous qui
avait porté une loi qui prônait la
confiance comment pensez vous instaurez
confiance et partenariat entre les
services publics de l'état et ceux des
collectivités locales afin que tous nos
concitoyens est le même accès au droit
pour vous répondre en a parlé
on secrétaire d'état produits d'actions
des comptes publics monsieur du shop
monsieur le ministre avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vais rien vous poser la
question de la permanence sur le
territoire du réseau de la dgfip vous
avez raison de souligner son importance
aujourd'hui la dg philippe compte 3800
points de contact c'est 1000 de moins
qu'il ya dix ans qui témoigne de des
réorganisations successives ces
réorganisations qui se traduisait par
des fermetures ont un défaut principal
au delà de la justification de certaines
du fait des évolutions technologiques
elles s'inscrivent dans des plans
annuels sont visibilité ni pour les
agents ni pour les élus locaux nous
avons demandé avec gérald darmanin à
l'ensemble des services du ministère
d'action des comptes publics de changer
cette méthode
cette nouvelle méthode va se traduire au
cours de l'année 2019 pas d'abord par
une méthode de concertation comme vous
l'appelez de vos voeux nous avons fixé
aux directeurs départementaux des
finances publiques en lien avec les
préfets trois objectifs le premier
objectif est d'avoir une vision
pluriannuelle de la réorganisation des
services de la dgfip de manière à donner
la visibilité aux territoires aux élus
locaux aux agents et aux contribuables
nous leur demandons s'il réfléchir à
l'échelle de bassin de vie et de bassins
d'emploi en s'extrayant des logiques
purement administrative et en
travaillant plus tôt à l'échelle d'une
région sans tenir compte des frontières
administratives du département qui bien
souvent sont artificielles dans le
quotidien de nos concitoyens et nous
leur avons demandé de travailler en
augmentant le nombre de points de
contact sur le territoire par tous les
moyens possibles
le maintien de perception mais aussi le
développement maison de services au
public et ma collègue jacqueline
gourault travail à harmoniser l'offre de
services dans les maisons de services au
public et veiller à ce que l'ensemble
des services de l'état puisse y
participer
j'ajoute madame la sénatrice deux points
le premier pour dire que nous veillions
dans cette entreprise là à garantir un
très bon niveau de conseil aux élus
locaux soit par les trésoriers eux mêmes
soit par la constitution des équipes de
référence polyvalente et organisés en
brigades et par ailleurs nous veillons
aussi à regarder comment des services
installé aujourd'hui à paris ou dans les
métropoles pourrait être à terme
installées dans les territoires ruraux
périurbains dans une entreprise de
déconcentration proximité j'ajoute si
vous me le permettez monsieur le
président que les orientations données
east 1 de l'action et des comptes
publics sont parfaitement conformes aux
instructions données par le premier
ministre à l'ensemble des ministres pour
ce qui concerne la réorganisation des
services de l'état sur le territoire
on n'avait rien cette concertation est
prévue entre le 15 février et 15 mars
toujours dans la même note
j'espère que vous la ferez après le
grand débat et j'entends bien votre
réponse
nous jugerons et si c'est le cas merci
la parole est à notre collègue martin
évrier pour le groupe de la république
en marge pour deux minutes
heureusement que chacun respecte son
taureau merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la mise du travail en 2018 691
1000 nouvelles sociétés ont vu le jour
le chômage a reculé de 1 25% en année le
nombre de procédures prud'homales a
chuté de plus de 17,61 pour 103
résultats encourageants directement lié
aux ordonnances réformant le code du
travail et aux actions menées durant ces
18 dernières années ils ont permis aux
entreprises de se stabiliser de
reconstituer leurs marges et de
redevenir compétitive leurs capacités de
sauvegarde et créer des emplois et à
réinvestir s'est renforcée
nous le savons tous c'est l'entreprise
qui génère la richesse qui créent de
l'emploi et permet à tous de mieux vivre
dans un contexte économique instable
le gouvernement a maintenu ce cap ainsi
le projet de loi de finances 2010 neuf
actes entre autres le transfert du cic
eux vers un allègement de cotisations
patronales pour un coût de 21 milliards
d'euros madame la ministre en novembre
vous avez lancé la négociation entre
partenaires sociaux sur l'assurance
chômage a des objectifs est de lutter
contre la précarité inciter les chômeurs
à retourner plus vite sur le marché du
travail
or lundi les organisations patronales
ont décidé de se retirer des
négociations
faisant suite aux déclarations du
président de la république sur le bonus
malus
ce dispositif consiste à moduler les
cotisations chômage de l'employeur en
fonction du taux de rupture de contrat
de travail
cette promesse présidentielle a trouvé
le soutien des syndicats et pour cause
en vingt ans les cdd de moins d'un mois
ont été multipliés par deux et demi
madame la ministre nous devons continuer
à libérer l'économie française tout en
protégeant le salarié et cela ne peut se
faire qu'avec la collaboration du medef
de la cgpme et de l'ue de paix
que comptez vous faire pour que les
organisations patronales réintègre la
thaïlande ait eu l'occasion je conclus
et dans l'éventualité d'un accord
quelles seraient les alternatives à la
taxation des contrats courts
je remercie madame la ministre vous avez
deux minutes maximum pour répondre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
messieurs le sénateur martin lévriers
vous avez souligné le début de la baisse
du chômage dont on est passé de 9,7 à
9,1 pour cent avec 250 mille emplois en
créations nettes
c'est encourageant je pense que nous
serons tous d'accord ici pour dire qu'il
faut aller il faut encore plus continuer
nos efforts pour aller dans ce sens-là
c'est le sens des ordonnances de la loi
pour la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel et le plan
d'investissement compétences dont je
peux vous dire d'ores et déjà que treize
régions sur quinze sur aux régions sur
treize pardon nous confirmer leur accord
pour signer ce pacte pour 4 ans ainsi
que tous les outre-mer
mais au-delà de ça un des leviers et ce
sont aussi les règles de l'assurance
chômage dans les règles d'assurance
chômage dans le document de cadrage que
le premier ministre a envoyé le 25
septembre dernier aux partenaires
sociaux trois sujets principaux sont
évoqués un premier concerne les règles
d'indemnisation des chômeurs puisque
dans 20% des cas ce n'est pas la
totalité
le cumul de plusieurs règles sans que
ces faits déterminés par les partenaires
sociaux et était voulue ou pour
conséquence que dans ces cas là un un
demandeur d'emploi indemnisé peu
avoir une indemnité qui est supérieur
chaque mois à ce qu'ils avaient en
travaillant chaque mois ce n'est pas
incitatif
il ya un autre sujet qui est très
important c'est la multiplication j'ai
si j'ose dire l'explosion des contrats
courts dans notre pays qu'à une
spécificité française
malheureusement qui concourent beaucoup
à la précarité dont on voit à quel point
elle est un sujet sensible à juste titre
dans la population
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
9 embauches sur dix sont un contrat en
cdd ou un intérim mais plus encore
aujourd'hui ce sont les cdd extrêmement
courts qui sont développés puisque ce
sont 80 % de cdd qui sont de trois mois
au moins
et aujourd'hui nous avons une explosion
des contrats de moins d'un mois en
particulier dans douze secteurs
professionnels qui ont multiplié par
deux et demi leur contrat extrêmement
court ah non une précarisation de tout
un secteur du pont du travail c'est donc
la responsabilité aussi des employeurs
de travailler sur ce sujet et avec le
premier ministre nous faisons confiance
à la négociation sociale pour trouver
des solutions sur ces deux sujets
obscures le désendettement de l'unedic
dont je rappelle qu'il ya 35 milliards
de da ble dette garantie par l'état
mes paroles et à notre collègue
françoise laborde pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour de l'onu merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances
l'aéroport régional toulouse blagnac vie
à un énième rebondissement avec
l'annoncé par le consortium chinois
quasi l'europe de la revente des 49 9%
de parts qu'il détient depuis 2015
les acteurs locaux sont las de ce
mauvais scénario sur lequel je me suis
maintes fois exprimée ici nous parlons
du cinquième aéroport régional et
premier aéroport régional de fret outils
de développement essentiel pour le
territoire infrastructures hautement
stratégiques notamment pour airbus qui
en est un utilisateur privilégié depuis
l'arrivée de quasi l'europe
un bras de fer s'est engagée concernant
la redistribution des dividendes
l'investisseur privé réclamant je cite
un retour sur investissement raisonnable
les collectivités locales n'ont cessé de
se poser
de s'opposer à la demande de
redistribution croissance qui atteint
fin 2010 8 100 % des bénéfices elles
n'ont pas plu est aidé par l' agence de
participation de l'état qui a
systématiquement valider les attentes de
l'investisseur privé
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous me
garantir que les derniers 10,1 pour cent
appartenant encore à l'état seront bien
désolidarisé de la vente par quasi
l'europe à tout nouvel acheteur privé
je propose d'étudier une vente des parts
de l'état aux collectivités locales qui
détiennent déjà ensemble 40% du capital
afin d'assurer une majorité stable et
sereine dans la gouvernance de cet
équipement je vous remercie
merci à bord le touriste de l'économie
et des finances monsieur le maire
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice la bande
en avril 2015
nous avons vendu 49 et 2 9% départ de
l'aéroport de toulouse nous avons mené
cette opération en respect des règles de
droit en faisant un appel à concurrence
un système d'enchères et donc nous avons
vendu comme c'est le cas dans n'importe
quel écho been marché à l'acheteur qui
était le plus offrant qui répondait au
cahier des charges
je rappelle que kelly l'était plus
offrants de 17% par rapport à l'an
scherrer qui venait en deuxième position
je rappelle également que la cour des
comptes a validé cette enchère et a
reconnu qu' elle était parfaitement
conforme aux règles de droit
je le dis pour ce qui pourrait contester
la légalité de cette opération qui ne se
gêne pas pour le faire
la troisième remarque que je tiens à
faire c'est que depuis 2015 qu'est ce
qui s'est passé sur l'aéroport de
toulouse les investissements sur
lesquelles ce gaz il était engagé ont
été faits le trafic a augmenté de 28%
des résultats financiers de l'entreprise
ont augmenté de 28%
tant que nous sommes dans une économie
de marché de devrions nous réjouir que
le report de toulouse est de nouveaux
investissements des financements qui
soit solide et des passagers qu'ils
soient plus nombreux
parce que c'est mieux ce que nous
cherchons le développement économique
ensuite il reste 10 % de parts qui
appartiennent à l'état
je vous fais une proposition honnête
madame la sénatrice
c'est de venir de venir me voir
avec les autres élus avec les autres
élus de la métropole avec la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et que nous
discutions de ce que vous voulez que
nous fassions nous prendrons la décision
ensemble chaud et 10% de participation
de l'état qui reste dans l'aéroport de
toulouse avec un seul objectif le
développement de votre aéroport à
lasbordes
merci monsieur le ministre j'avoue que
votre réponse me convient et que je
viendrais parce que je pense que c'est
important que nous puissions discuter de
cet équipement qui n'est pas n'importe
quel équipement et donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut le traiter différemment et j'espère
que le les collectivités pourront garder
les 10,1 pour cent restants je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame lienemann pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes devait la parole ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre les géants du numérique les
gars femme paie des impôts dérisoire
dans notre pays notre groupe depuis
plusieurs années dans le débat
budgétaire a déposé des amendements pour
stopper cette injustice
elle ce manque à gagner le sénat
au delà de nos différences politiques
les a à plusieurs reprises voter et
récemment encore lors de la loi de
finances
le gouvernement les a rejetées on ne
pouvait agir qu'au niveau européen voire
à l' ocde
certes c'est indispensable mais cela
n'empêchait pas la france d'agir en
précurseur et de façon unilatérale sur
la pression de l'opinion vous en
convenez désormais et promettez de taxer
les gars femmes que de temps et d'argent
perdu mais c'est taxation ne doit pas
être symbolique
d'abord le cadre doit être durable
ces entreprises doivent être taxés comme
toutes celles installées sur notre
territoire alors proposerez-vous comme
le sénat
que les géants du numérique soit
considérée comme établissement stable en
france dès lors que leur chiffre
d'affaires dépasse un certain seuil dans
notre pays
porterez-vous cette exigence à luz et
des eaux ensuite les discussions
européennes prévoit une taxe de 3% sur
les chiffres d'affaires
mais sous la pression de l'allemagne la
base prise en compte pour le chiffre
d'affaires a fondu comme neige au soleil
initialement la france pouvait escompter
un milliard d'euros de recettes en
rythme de croisière avec l'accord
franco-allemand que vous avez approuvé
elle ne serait plus que de 400 millions
ce qui vous en conviendrez est assez
dérisoire au regard de leurs profits
alors proposerez-vous une base large de
taxation permettant une recette
d'environ un milliard d'euros pour notre
pays
nous sommes inquiets car les
informations d'ap rès n'ont pas l'air
d'aller en ce sens il en va de la
justice fiscale entre citoyens et
entreprises entre entreprises pme qui
payent beaucoup et multinationales qui
paye peut il en va des moyens dont la
france ont besoin
il est urgent que les fils de la femme
payent leur dû monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances
madame la sénatrice lienemann ça nous
arrivera
rarement je pense dans cet hémicycle
mais pour une fois je suis d'accord avec
vous il est indispensable de taxer sans
délai les géants du numérique
c'est une question de justice personne
ne peut accepter que les géants du
numérique qui font les profits les plus
élevés paye 14 points d'impôts de moins
que n'importe quelle pme de france ou
d'europe et c'est une question
d'efficacité
parce que si nous voulons demain pouvoir
financer nos services publics nos
crèches aux hôpitaux nos écoles
ben il faut aller chercher l'argent là
où il se trouve et c'est ce que nous
allons faire et c'est ce que nous allons
faire à la demande
à la demande du premier ministre nous
déposerons dans les prochains jours un
projet de loi sur la taxation des géants
du numérique
cette taxation nationale des gens du
numérique touchera toutes les
entreprises qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires numérique supérieures à 750
millions d'euros et un chiffre
d'affaires national supérieur à 25
millions d'euros la taxation sera
progressive cela devrait vous plaire
pour que les petits pays moins que l'ego
et le rapport de cette taxe sera
d'environ 500 millions d'euros chaque
année
mais je ne baisse pas les bras pour que
nous obtenions aussi l'accord des 27
états membres de l'union européenne sur
une taxation européenne des gens du
numérique parce que tout de même plutôt
que d'avoir une taxe française italienne
espagnole et britannique
il serait mieux que l'europe est enfin
le courage d'assumer ses positions de
défendre ses intérêts économiques et de
taxer de manière souveraine
les géants du numérique dans le monde
nous nous battrons conclu
et j'espère qu'avec votre y compris au
niveau européen nous aurons d'une cause
pour la justice et l'efficacité du
système fiscal du 21e siècle
merci la parole est à notre collègue
xavier iacovelli promet groupe
socialiste et républicain
il avait la parole pour deux minutes
elle aurait bien que résidant intentions
de temps soit respectée merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des solidarités chez ministre deux morts
par semaine un viol toutes les heures
40% des sans domicile fixe de moins de
25 ans sont d'anciens enfants placés 70%
des jeunes qui sortent de la zone sont
sans diplôme
monsieur le ministre il s'est levé dans
tout autre pays un vent d'indignation
sur le sort de que la république réserve
à ses enfants
il aura fallu un documentaire choc sur
france 3 la mobilisation des députés et
sénateurs de tous les bords politiques
et l'émotion des français pour que le
gouvernement se décide enfin à agir
indignation monsieur le ministre qui a
conduit à votre nomination de 25 janvier
dernier en 18 mois votre gouvernement a
perdu la confiance de l'ensemble des
acteurs de la protection de l'enfance en
en faisant l'angle mort de votre
politique
cette confiance il est de votre devoir
de la retrouver cette situation
dramatique ne date pas d'hier
les départements qui sont confrontés à
la baisse des dotations à l'augmentation
des placements et des suivis ne peuvent
plus gérer seul la prise des charges de
ses enfants
comment accepter que l'aide sociale à
l'enfance censé être le lieux de
protection devienne le lieu de
reproduction des violences contre
lesquels les enfants doivent être
protégés
comment accepter que perdure de telles
inégalités de prise en charge des
terriers d'un territoire à l'autre
sortie sèche de l'ac2a 18 ans
vieillissement des familles d'accueil
absence de fichier national pour
l'agrément notre système de protection
de l'enfance est aujourd'hui à bout de
souffle
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre
préciser quel est votre périmètre
le périmètre de votre ministère et quels
seront les moyens attribués pour la
protection de l'enfance sachant que rien
n'était prévu dans le budget 2010 9 en
tant que député vous avez signé la
proposition de loi pour éviter les
sorties sèches des jeunes majeurs en
tant que ministre allez-vous soutenir
les initiatives parlementaires pour vous
répondre
le secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur adrien taquet merci monsieur le
président pour votre votre accueil
mesdames et messieurs et sénatrices les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur iacovelli
je vous remercie pour votre question
tout d'abord ce qu'elle me permet de
saluer ce département des hauts-de-seine
qui nous est chère à vous et à moi dont
nous sommes tous les deux issus notre
question permet de saluer ensuite votre
engagement votre engagement fox en
faveur la protection de l'enfance sujet
dont je sais qu'il vous est cher et nous
partageons cette nous partageons cette
préoccupation salue enfin l'initiative
qui est la vôtre il ya quelques jours
avec certains un certain nombre de votre
de vos collègues et je ne peux que
saluer cette initiative et au delà
au-delà de votre travail celui de
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
des affaires sociales qui travaillent
sur ce sujet vous me rejoindrez je pense
pour dire que la préoccupation la
situation est trop grande pour qu'elle
puisse être le monopole d'une couleur
politique ou de certains bancs autour
d'eux au sein de cette assemblée soit
ils ont convaincu je ne serai pas le
ministre qui oppose les parents à leurs
enfants qui oppose les juges aux avocats
qui opposerait les travailleurs sociaux
à leur employeur je ne serai pas le
ministre qui opposera les départements à
l'état je ne serai pas le ministre qui
opposera cette partie là de l'hémicycle
à celle ci je serai le mythe de la
concertation et du dialogue
oui un dialogue franc et sincère où on
se dit les choses dans les yeux et où
chacun chacun assume ses responsabilités
un dialogue qui est sûre qui est associé
à votre assemblée les départements et
les communes
ces territoires que vous représentez les
associations les professionnels de santé
que vous avez cités et du monde éducatif
les enfants oui les enfants et les
parents pour trouver ensemble des
solutions trouver ensemble des solutions
pour prévenir les violences tout d'abord
en accompagnant les parents et les
futurs parents trouver des solutions
ensemble pour mieux repérer ces
violences foraco cuvée des solutions
ensemble pour protéger efficacement les
enfants victimes
pour leur offrir des parcours de vie
stable notamment la sortie de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
enfin pour leur garantir les droits
fondamentaux comme l'éducation et la
santé
je vous remercie je soyez sûr que je
serai au rendez vous et je compte sur
vous et sur l'ensemble des membres de
cette assemblée pour qu'on vous faisant
des solutions d'ici à l'été prochain je
remercie iacovelli quelques secondes
oui mais monsieur le ministre
malheureusement je ne suis pas
complètement satisfait de votre réponse
et notamment sur le périmètre et sur les
moyens qui vous sont attribués
puisque votre ministre de tutelle a
déclaré le jour de votre nomination
devant le cnpe que vous n'aviez ni
budget et que vous étiez secrétaire
d'état à l'enfance contredisant du coup
le premier ministre quelques minutes
avant
concernant ses dents passion nous sommes
effectivement qu aucun responsable
monsieur le ministre il ya urgence et
nous comptons sur votre action
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
la présidente sophie primas pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé de la ville
et du logement que je remercie pour sa
présence monsieur le ministre
voici presque deux ans vous avez pris
les rênes de ce ministère sous une forme
ou sous une autre et les choix du
gouvernement ont désormais des
conséquences sur la marche du pays
force est de constater que la relance du
logement a été l'une de vos premières
préoccupations
malheureusement ce fut aussi la cible
des foudres de bercy la construction du
logement connaît aujourd'hui un sérieux
ralentissement les chiffres 2018 sont
inquiétants le nombre de mises en
chantier a baissé de 18% en 2018
coup de frein qui s'est amplifié en fin
d'année plus grave le nombre de permis
de construire délivrés ce qui fait
l'avenir baisse en 2018 et le recul au
quatrième trimestre s'est accentuée
enfin peut-être encore plus inquiétant
le taux d'annulation des logements
collectifs autorisés ont atteint en fin
d'année 27,3 pour cent le gouvernement
voulait être jugé sur ses résultats
nous y sommes exclusion de certaines
zones du dispositif pinel la fin de
l'acccident de la paix est là
session la limitation du prêt à taux
zéro la coupe dans les ressources des
bailleurs sociaux
toutes ces décisions purement budgétaire
auront produit leurs effets
malheureusement sur tous ces bancs lors
de l'examen des pl est fin 2018 en 2019
ou de la loi élan les sénateurs vous
avait alerté sur les conséquences
président prévisible de vos choix
philippe dallier dominique estrosi entre
autres ne regrettez vous pas monsieur le
ministre
quand vous voyez les chiffres de ce
bilan de ne pas avoir écouté le sénat au
projet de loi de finances comme vous
l'avez mieux fait en loi élan bon et
pour la parole et au ministère du
logement monsieur de normandie vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente prima vous l'avez
vous avez raison vous l'avez évoqué les
chiffres de la construction en 2018 sont
moins bons que ceux de 2017 c'est à peu
près un peu moins de 400 mille logements
qui ont été commencées à peu près quatre
cent soixante mille logements qui ont
été autorisés
ça reste néanmoins vis-à-vis de l'année
2007 qui était une année exceptionnelle
ça reste néanmoins des chiffres qui sont
bien supérieurs à la moyenne des cinq
dernières années c'est à peu près de
25000 logements commencés de plus que
sur la moyenne des cinq dernières années
mais peu importe cela ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays il
manque encore significativement des
logements songez qu'au moment où je vous
parle on construit à peu près autant de
logements qu'au début des années 80
alors qu'il y à 13 millions de
concitoyens en plus et une pression sur
les logements de plus en plus forte avec
notamment des divorces qui se sont
multipliés et alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire vis-à-vis de cela il ya trois
choses principales la première c'est de
mettre en oeuvre massivement et avec
beaucoup de rapidité la loi élan sur
laquelle vous êtes impliqué madame la
présidente ainsi que madame la
rapporteur dominique estrosi sassone je
vous remercie d'ailleurs parce que vous
avez accepté de participer à ce comité
de suivi inédit que nous lançons dès
mardi prochain en votre présence
avec également vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale deuxièmement il
faut lever les inquiétudes lever les
inquiétudes là où elle se trouve
notamment dans le logement social nous
étions hier avec votre collègue monsieur
le sénateur d'alliés pour la deuxième
réunion de la clause de revoyure et je
salue la présence et la participation
active de monsieur le sénateur d'allier
à ces travaux
le troisième élément qu'il nous faut
faire c'est absolument pouvoir
poursuivre la réhabilitation également
des logements parce qu'il s'avère qu'il
ya la construction il faut la soutenir
par le truchement de la loi élan là où
elle est nécessaire mais il ya aussi la
réhabilitation ou les chiffres pour le
coup sont bien meilleures puisque cette
année si je ne prends que peu l'anah
uniquement l'activité de l'anah c'est
17% de plus de réhabilitation qui ont
été opérés et je crois que un certain
nombre de tragédies notamment le drame
de marseille nous ont rappelé au combien
cette réhabilitation était nécessaire et
que cette approche de logements que je
sais vous partagez madame la présidente
d'une approche différenciée en fonction
des territoires et peut-être ce qui a
manqué pendant un bouton et ce qu'ils
nous font aujourd'hui remettre en place
oui merci monsieur le ministre de cette
réponse mais vous savez très bien
monsieur le ministre je m'adresse aussi
au premier ministre danser danser dans
son budget que la sensibilité du
logement au budget aux décisions
budgétaires est extrêmement forte et
quand on a mis un coup de frein aussi
fort que celui qu'on a mis cette année
et bien pour redémarrer cette
construction ça sera extrêmement
compliqué et malgré la loi est lent
malgré la simplification qu'on est en
train d'opérer avec pacte tout ça n'aura
pas d'effet si on met pas un moment les
moyens pour le logement
merci la parole et à notre collègue
nathalie goulet
mais pour le groupe de l'union centriste
avait la parole messieurs mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre la
plupart des pays dont la france exige
des gens qui voyagent en france et
ailleurs un billet de retour
c'était normal ça évite les problèmes et
sa garantie eu le retour des gens qui
viennent sur le territoire or il se
trouve que des entreprises pleine de
créativité ont initié la vente de
billets provisoire sur internet c'est à
dire que ces billets pour 7 à 30 dollars
sont valables entre quelques heures et
plusieurs jours c'est à dire que quand
vous vous présentez à la passerelle de
l'avion et au contrôle vous avez un
billet de retour
et puis quand vous avez
c'est les bagages de voeux pays
destination le biais s'évapore voilà
donc c'est un faux billet vrai faux
billets sont utilisés pour obtenir un
visa y compris un visa schengen
voyez-vous et donc je peux vous donner
la référence des sites mais je voudrais
pas leur créer trop de publicité donc ma
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre
dans la période que nous traversons
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour éviter ce type de procédure et et
faire en sorte soit au niveau national
et en tous les cas au niveau européen
que on limite les effets dévastateurs de
ces agences très créatrice pour vous
répondre la parole et comme monsieur
milices de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe scolaire monsieur ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice à
travers votre question sur ces faux
billets ou ses billets temporaire vous
poser celle plus globale au fond des
fraudes documentaires des fraudes
documentaires que nous retrouvons sur
les questions d'identité et qu'ils aient
perpétré dans des pays tiers et qui a
tendance effectivement à prendre de
l'ampleur
c'est une ampleur que vous évoquez dont
nous avons conscience que nous devons
combattre parce que ces tentatives de
fraude elles peuvent se manifester à
toutes les étapes du parcours migratoire
y compris d'un pays à l'autre dans les
pays de transit et nous faut sur ces
sujets être très vigilant parce que pour
certains pays font l'obtention d'un visa
et pour traverser ce pays pour venir
ensuite vers un pays schengen
on a des faux visas on a aussi des
titres de séjour et globalement c'est
aussi une fraude documentaire qui permet
d'échapper à tous nos dispositifs qui
sont consécutifs à l'éloignement qui
peut être mises en oeuvre et qui du coup
aujourd'hui permettent d'empêcher
d'empêcher une bonne lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière parce que dans
ce pays il ya des règles il ya des
règles qui se veulent généreuse sur
l'accueil des personnes en situation de
réfugiés qui doivent être appliquées
pour des migrations économiques pour des
migrants qui n'ont pas vocation à rester
dans notre pays vous m'interrogez sur
les moyens que nous mettons en oeuvre et
son de plusieurs niveaux d'abord dans
chaque département pour travailler sur
l'ensemble des filières nous avons mis
en place une un comité opérationnel
départemental anti fraude qui associe le
préfet le procureur pour travailler sur
tous ces sujets on a la connaissance là
en aval c'est-à-dire à l'arrivée d'un
certain nombre d'informations qui
peuvent nous permettre de lutter contre
les filières en 2018 nous avons
démantelé 52 filière qu'ils utilisent et
qui mettaient en place des faux
documents
près de douze mille agents ont été
formés aussi pour travailler sur ces
sujets et pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse avancer nous multiplions aussi
les officiers de liaison dans les
aéroports les plus sensibles pour
utiliser un euphémisme pour justement
détecter ces faux papiers et ses
arnaques sur les billets d'avion l'année
dernière c'est près de cartes de 49000
documents qui ont été analysés à la
demande de différents services police
préfecture tribunaux et il est
nécessaire que nous maintenions l'effort
parce qu'effectivement nul ne peut
pouvoir contourner ces règles
fondamentales et nous devons sur ces
sujets être extrêmement vigilant en
particulier sur les faux billets d'avion
[Applaudissements]
madame la sénatrice wii u ces mini sûr
merci moi je suis un petit troubles
obsessionnels compulsifs sur la fraude
documentaire vous savez et donc je
voulais quand même vous signaler on
l'avait déjà signalé dans le cadre de la
du rapport sur les réseaux djihadistes
vous savez que la police de l'air et des
frontières n'a toujours pas accès au
fichier tess c'est quand même très
réducteur de leurs capacités par
ailleurs en ce qui concerne les mesures
d'usurpation d'identité je pense qu'il
faudra renforcer les articles 44 141
441,2 dans la future loppsi
il faut renforcer les sanctions et puis
s'agissant de la fraude documentaire
notamment en matière de sécurité sociale
je voudrais remercier l'initiative du
rapporteur général du budget de la
sécurité sociale qui va enfin procéder à
une enquête sur pièces et sur place
en ce qui concerne les faux numéros dean
c'est qu'ils sont un sujet
régulier de problème compte tenu des
montants extrêmement important de fraude
documentaire jour merci merci d'abord
l'état de nos collègues francophones en
ville voir le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture
elle porte sur la peste porcine
africaine maladie hémorragique virale
strictement animal la peste porcine
africaine est à paris en europe de l'est
il y a cinq ans elle a peu à peu avancée
vers l'ouest du continent pour atteindre
la belgique le 13 septembre dernier
neuf pays de l'union européenne sont
déjà concernés
deux nouveaux cas ont été détectés en
belgique le 14 janvier dernier
à moins de deux kilomètres de la
frontière non transmissible à l'homme
il faut le rappeler elle se révèle
toutefois extrêmement contagieuse pour
les porcins et les sangliers les risques
d'une arrivée en france du virus sont
considérables tout d'abord pour notre
agriculture en particulier pour la
filière porcine car au-delà donc du
risque sanitaire et de la mortalité
c'est aussi le marché de l'exportation
qui se fermerait entraînant
l'anéantissement des débouchés pour les
producteurs
l'industrie agroalimentaire ne serait
sans doute pas épargné non plus un fort
risque pèse aussi sur la biodiversité
sur l'activité forestière est sûre
l'économiste cynégétique
vous avez pris des mesures de prévention
dans la mise en place d'une zone blanche
où sont éradiqués tous les sangliers
principaux vecteurs de la propagation et
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer la forte
mobilisation des chasseurs
monsieur le ministre pouvait nous dire
s'il vous pouvez vous nous dire si la
france est toujours un thème quelles
mesures à moyen et long terme entendez
vous mettre en place pour lutter contre
ce fléau
comment comptez vous accompagner et
protéger nos éleveurs et on va enfin
pouvez vous nous dire comment s'articule
la coordination avec les autorités
belges
si pour vous répondre la parole et table
sur ministre de l'agriculture monsieur
didier guillaume monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur frank maintenant
ville merci pour votre question et merci
pour votre implication
pressé de régler ce problème comme l'ont
très bien fait avec lesquels nous
travaillons beaucoup benoît huré gérard
longuet et marc laménie avec lesquels il
a en fait déjà plusieurs réunions sur le
sur le sur le terrain cette situation
situation est très préoccupante est très
grave pour la france vous l'avez dit la
france est indemne
cette maladie ne peut pas elle n'est pas
transmissible à l'homme par contre cette
maladie transmissible à tous les
élevages porcins avec deux risques
si un cas de peste porcine africaine été
découvert en france plus aucun port à
l'export dès le lendemain c'est à dire
c'est la moitié de de la filière porcine
qui deviendrait dans un drôle d'état et
la deuxième la deuxième chose c'est tout
simplement qu'il faudrait comme il n'ya
pas de régionalisation il ferait
vraisemblement faire disparaître la
plupart de l'élevage porcin en france la
france est indemne
nous travaillons beaucoup avec la avec
la belgique depuis le 8 janvier
quand deux sangliers tués à côté de la
frontière est atteint par la maladie ont
des découverts
nous avons réhausser le niveau de
biosécurité des élevages réhausser le
niveau de sécurité de notre pays et
réhaussée et mis en place une task force
avec les belges où toutes les 48 heures
nous nous travaillons
enfin troisième chose après l'audition
de m un vide sanitaire 43 km de long 6
km de large à l'intérieur duquel nous
devons tuer tous les sangliers
je veux remercier l'ensemble des
services de l'état le préfet la draf le
ntfs le nf les chasseurs vous là vous
l'avez dit toute la filière inaporc la
fédération nationale porcine
la mobilisation générale est décrétée il
faut maintenant gagner et pour gagner il
faut éradiquer la présence de sangliers
dans cette zone qui doit être totalement
une zone blanche le premier ministre a
autorisé à ce que nous soyons aidées par
l'armée des militaires 30 40 50 par jour
aider le travail qui est fait évidemment
pas pour tirer sur les sangliers mais
pour les pièger pour le transport de
deux cadavres
aujourd'hui nous avons environ 900
personnes qui organisent des battues
régulière nous en sommes à 200 250
sangliers il faut aller plus loin
mesdames et messieurs si ce n'est des
chasseurs de sangliers dans l'hémicycle
faites vous connaître vous serez les
bienvenus pour faire des beaux tableaux
je remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue propre nom
vite pardonné voir il avait les
observations non la parole est à notre
collègue chez un marché pour le groupe
mais république à monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale mais je crois qu'il n'est pas
là il y a un an je vous interrogeait
déjà sur les projets de fermetures de
classes dans les communes rurales de
notre pays
aujourd'hui la situation qui s'annonce
est encore pire
vos promesses se sont envolés des
dizaines de classes vont encore fermées
et la france périphérique se sent plus
que jamais abandonné en seine-et-marne
en annonce près de 180 fermetures
touchent en plus de 150 communes sur 507
contre moins d'un tiers d'ouverture les
habitants sont exaspérés les élus locaux
sont désespérés nos villes et nos
villages ne pourront pas faire face
monsieur le ministre en fermant ses
classes quel avenir réservé vous au
monde rural
la parole pour vous répondez que
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
si vous avez la parole merci à monsieur
le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice chien larcher je vous prie
d'excuser effectivement jean-michel
bancaire qui est à l'assemblée nationale
pour l'examen d'une proposition de loi
sur l'école inclusive vous posez la
question de l'école et dans la ruralité
qui est un sujet un sujet sensible parce
qu'il renvoie à la question de la
présence des services publics dans nos
territoires et dans nos territoires
ruraux en particulier sur ce sujet je
veux rappeler l'effort colossal
budgétaire qui a été déployée par le
gouvernement depuis deux ans pour
renforcer la présence colère dans la
ruralité vous prenez les 45 départements
les plus ruraux en 2017 et 2018
ces quarante mille élèves en moins et
pourtant 400 postes créés en plus la
démographie aurait dû conduire
mathématiquement lefa statistiquement
comme c'est prévu selon les règles à la
suppression de postes la suppression de
casse de classe c des postes
supplémentaires qui ont été créés ça va
se poursuivre en 2010 neuf puisque on
attend encore une baisse démographique
et que au national de 1235 postes seront
créés dans votre département de
seine-et-marne
ces 700 élèves en moins qui sont
attendus à la rentrée 2010 9
ce sera 40 professeurs en plus qui
arriveront en seine et marne à la
rentrée 2010 9 c'est donc un effort
important je veux insister sur le fait
que le président de la république s'est
engagé lors de la conférence nationale
des territoires à ce qu'il y ait une
vigilance accrue des services
académiques sur la question des
fermetures de classes et plus gravement
encore sur la question des fermetures
d'écoles dans la ruralité parce que
c'est un sujet qui peut se présenter si
à une baisse drastique de la démographie
si on veut maintenir un niveau de
qualité éducative importance et des
sujets qui peuvent se poser
ils doivent toujours se poser en lien
avec les élus locaux évidemment avec les
parlementaires du territoire c'est la
consigne qui est donné aux services
académiques
je rappelle par ailleurs que à ce stade
vous faites référence à la rentrée
prochaine
toutes les fermetures et ouvertures de
classes qui sont annoncés au prévus sont
conditionnelles rien n'a été acté rien
n'est acté c'est bien les inscriptions
constater les anticipations constater
qu'ils décideront bien plus tard dans
l'année des ouvertures et fermetures de
classes je veux aussi rappeler que nous
avons déployé deux conventions ruralité
une dizaine en 2018 grâce notamment à
l'implication du sénateur alain durand
votre collègue et qu'une mission est en
cours avec madame azéma et monsieur
macho pour travailler sur la question de
l'éducation et des territoires et
notamment de la ruralité
nous aurons ces retours dans les
prochaines semaines et sans doute
sera-t-il des adaptations à prévoir au
niveau national je vous remercie madame
aicha marché
messieurs ministre des adaptations ou
les attendons effectivement parce que
l'art et rallie la réalité je vais vous
la dire c'est dans un même regroupement
pédagogique de fermeture en deux ans
coup sur coup
comment voulez vous que les maires phase
où nous parler chiffres choix
perspective est fort mais qui fait des
efforts nous vous parlons d'enfants qui
sont nos adultes de demain dont le seul
tort est de vivre à la campagne mais
aussi d' équipe d'enseignants qui font
un travail remarquable et qui ont besoin
de stabilité de villes et de villages
dont le
miss va être anéanti des territoires qui
souffrent et que vous refuser d'entendre
après les entreprises les commerces les
médecins maintenant les écoles mais ces
français que vous voyez comme ceux qui
ne sont rien et ceux qui roulent au
diesel et fument des clopes
eux aussi sont la france vous leur
promettez un grand débat et en même
temps vous ne leur laissait aucune
chance
tout cela n'est qu'enfumage vous
organisez la france des clivages vous ne
répare et pas la france comme cela
la parole est à notre collègue pascal
allizard pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
ces dernières années de nombreux
français ont rejoint les rangs de l'état
islamique au levant acquis à la cause
salafistes portée par la volonté de
contribuer au djihad armé ils se sont
rendu tristement célèbre par le haut
parleur exactions commises contre les
populations locales pour imposer l'ordre
tyrannique de dèche
il voulait aussi mettre la france à
genoux certains d'entre eux utilisant
les réseaux sociaux ont largement
diffuser leur propagande visant à
encourager de jeunes français à les
rejoindre ou à commettre des attentats
sur notre sol par tous les moyens
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de ces
individus dangereux capturés en syrie
sont détenus par les forces kurdes
le désengagement américain du levant
pose la question du devenir de ces
prisonniers qui pourrait revenir en
france
dès lors comment le gouvernement tente
il protéger efficacement les français de
ces criminels de ses ennemis de la
république
et alors que la menace terroriste reste
très élevé dans notre pays ciom pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre je président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur allizard vous
m'interrogez sur le sort des français
terroristes détenus au nord-est de la
syrie
je voudrais commencer par dire que votre
préoccupation celle qui sous-tend votre
question la préoccupation du premier
ministre que je suis des membres du
gouvernement de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
j'en suis certain c'est de faire en
sorte de garantir la sécurité des
français
c'est pour garantir la sécurité des
français que des gouvernements ont
décidé d'aller combattre des shs dans
cette région et de participer à une
coalition
c'est pour garantir la sécurité des
français qu'un certain nombre
d'opérations ont été conduites
face à des terroristes qui quelle que
soit la nationalité dont ils pouvaient
le cas échéant se revendiquait étaient
des ennemis et ont extrait de traiter
comme tel il se trouve qu'un certain
nombre de combattants français qui se
sont rendus sur place ont été parfois
rejoints par leurs conjoints ont parfois
eu des enfants il se trouve que certains
ont été tués dans des combats que
d'autres sont aujourd'hui en détention
par les forces kurdes dans le nord-est
de la syrie
l'objectif notre objectif c'est
évidemment de faire en sorte que ceux
qui ont commis ces crimes
et il ne s'agissait pas d'une visite de
courtoisie à l'est au cours de ces
années dans cette région
c'est clairement faire un choix notre
objectif c'est que ferran de faire en
sorte que ceux qui ont fait ce choix
soit jugé soit condamné et soient punis
à la hauteur de leurs crimes et leurs
crimes sont immenses mais monsieur le
sénateur
lorsque en irak lorsqu en irak un
certain nombre de ces français qui se
sont rendus coupables de crimes commis
en irak ont été arrêtés détenus jugés et
condamnés
nous n'avons rien trouvé à redire la
situation est un peu différente et vous
le savez parfaitement votre question
l'illustrent dans le nord-est de la
syrie pourquoi parce que ceux qui sont
détenus aujourd'hui sont détenus par les
kurdes parce que la décision unilatérale
des états unis de se désengager de la
syrie a suscité chez les kurdes des
interrogations considérables et
pourraient susciter et je le dis
évidemment avec beaucoup de prudence car
je suis incapable de la firme est ici
mais pourrait susciter des décisions de
réorganisation de l'effort des forces
d'autres priorités qui pourrait là
encore je le dis avec prudence avoir
pour effet non pas de garder en
détention
ces terroristes mais de les relâcher de
les disperser
et vous voyez bien monsieur le sénateur
qu'il n'est dans l'intérêt de personne
et certainement pas de notre pays de
voir se disperser des ennemis de la
france
ce que je veux dire monsieur le sénateur
c'est que si ces personnes sont expulsés
de syrie
et si elle venait à être en contact avec
les autorités françaises elles seraient
autant d'émoi bien immédiatement arrêté
soumis à la justice
et je l'espère je le crois puni et punis
sévèrement
c'est notre objectif faire en sorte que
ceux qui se sont rendus coupables de
crimes et le simple fait d'avoir été sur
place et souvent déjà constitutifs d'un
crime puisse être condamné
notre intérêt je le redis parce que j'ai
entendu beaucoup de
prises de position sur ce sujet depuis
quelques jours beaucoup étaient
empreintes de vraies inquiétudes
beaucoup étaient empreintes d'une vraie
hauteur de vue certaines étaient
empreintes parfois de très grande
facilité et d'une facilité confondante
je dois dire notre objectif encore une
fois c'est l'intérêt objectif de la
france c'est qu' il n'y ait pas de
dispersion de ces terroristes
nous prendrons donc toutes nos
responsabilités et nous mettons en place
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour faire en
sorte que si ces personnes venaient à
être expulsées elles puissent faire
l'objet de procédures judiciaires
extrêmement sévères de la part de notre
pays monsieur malige à monsieur le
premier ministre il faut dire la vérité
aux français
ces prisonniers seront ils échangent et
avant ce retour par les milices contre
des prisonniers détenus par beige
c'est un risque que vous n'avez pas cité
par ailleurs la réponse judiciaire en
faire les revenants majeur vous le savez
est tributaire de la preuve ils
tenteront tout pour minimiser leur rôle
un dossier judiciaire fragile c'est une
condamnation faibles assuré et un retour
dans la société à brève échéance ce
n'est pas acceptable
enfin c'est un problème dont l'europe
doit se saisir car les jihadistes
comporte de nouveaux de nombreux
européens dans leurs rangs
la charte de londres et le statut de
rome vous le savez le permettent
nous parlons ici de crimes de guerre de
crimes contre l'humanité et de génocide
je crois que votre volte face n'est que
le marqueur d'une certaine faiblesse de
la politique étrangère au levant ils ne
doivent pas revenir
merci les prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement auront lieu
le 5 février nation si suspendait
jusqu'à césure 20 pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
croissance et la transformation des
entreprises séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement où il a été
question de sujets internationaux et
notamment de la guerre en syrie avec 130
djihadiste français qui pourraient être
relâchés par les forces kurdes et
revenir en france avec une question du
sénateur les républicains pascal
allizard qui estime que ces djihadistes
ne doivent pas revenir en france car il
prit car ils constituent un danger pour
la sécurité nationale
edouard philippe le premier ministre lui
a répondu en estimant qu'il fallait
éviter la dispersion sur le territoire
syrien de ces djihadistes et que si
jamais il était expulsé du territoire
syrien et qu'il venait en contact avec
les frontières françaises ces
djihadistes seraient arrêtés par les
autorités françaises jugé et condamné
sévèrement pour éviter leur dispersion
et puis là il était question de la crise
au venezuela et notamment de la
répression du président nicholas maduro
sur des centaines et des milliers de
manifestants dans son pays
le président du groupe les indépendants
au sénat claude malhuret a dénoncé cette
répression et à dénoncer le régime de
nicolás maduro un régime soutenu par un
certain jean luc mélenchon qualifié avec
humour par claude malhuret de lider
minimo claude malhuret qui a également
dénoncé l'arrestation de deux
journalistes français de l'émission
quotidien et loire philippe a annoncé
que le ministère des affaires étrangères
avait demandé la libération immédiate de
ces journalistes français voilà pour ces
deux moments forts de ces questions
d'actualité du sénat au gouvernement
merci à vous alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions on va continuer d'analyser
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement avec mon invité j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir martha dos idrac
bonjour vous êtes à l ère des yvelines a
beaucoup de questions aujourd'hui à
commencer par l'interdiction des
lanceurs de balles de défense on sait
qu'il ya une proposition de loi
communiste qui sera débattue au mois de
mars prochain
le mouvement des gilet jaune qui
continue un sa mobilisation
chaque samedi et rythmée par une
nouvelle manifestation parfois de plus
en plus violente avec d'un côté et bien
à les policiers et cet usage
le contester des flash ball est ce que
vous vous seriez favorable à leur
interdiction
alors je crois que de toute façon par
principe il faut condamner toutes les
violences quelles qu'elles soient d'où
qu'elles viennent
ça ça me paraît fondamental et je crois
que c'est quelque chose que nous
partageons tous collectivement
de ce point de vue s'agissant en fait
des flash-balls bien évidemment un usage
non conforme doit être condamné et doit
être évidemment regardé avec vigilance
toutefois il est vrai que ces polémiques
est réapparu suit en fait à certaines
manifestations à certains actes autour
des gilet jaune
je ne pense pas qu'il faille non plus
généraliser les ces mauvais usage
il y en aura il y en aura toujours donc
personnellement je pense qu'il ne faut
pas démunir nos forces de l'ordre de
ceux qui est aussi un moyen pour eux de
pouvoir être efficaces dans leur mission
et personnellement je moi je suis pour
ne pas déshabiller notre nos forces de
l'ordre et je ne suis pas favorable
forcément à la suppression donc des
outils que notre police a aujourd'hui en
revanche bien évidemment il faut que
nous soyons tous collectivement
vigilants à leur usage c'est vrai que je
vous ferai un autre sujet mais avant
cela on va retourner en salle des
conférences et le principe de cette
émission puisque tam tran huy et aux
côtés du ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement marc fesneau
oui marc fesneau vous êtes déclaré
favorable à un retour partiel au cumul
des mandats notamment pour les maires de
petites villes
alors françois patriat a jugé ce matin
qu'on pouvait prévoir un seuil à 2500
habitants
que pensez vous de cette proposition moi
je pense qu'il faut que le débat se noue
c'est une
c'est une réflexion qui font qu'on porte
ça fait deux ans que la la fin du cumul
des mandats est à l'oeuvre et on voit
bien la fois ce que ça peut produire
dutil quand même on voit bien que
parfois le cumul des mandats bien très
gros exécutif avec un mandat
parlementaire poser des questions de
disponibilité tout simplement et
entendre les écueils qu'on a au travers
de cette affaire là c'est à dire le fait
que deux mondes sont en train de
cohabiter désormais alors qu'avant ils
se mélangent et le monde des élus locaux
et le monde des élus nationaux ce n'est
pas le seul fait du non cumul effraction
vous verrez avec elle il faut regarder
ça avec tranquillité sans rentrer dans
la caricature je pas dit que c'était la
seule question qui était en cause mais
en tout cas c'est une question qu'il
faut interroger tranquillement les
questions de seuils viendront peut-être
si la question est posée et je pense que
c'est une question aussi pour les
territoires intermédiaire où les
territoires ruraux en particulier qui
était de celles de dire est-ce que
compte tenu du fait que nous n'avons
plus de représentants nationaux ne
seront pas moins représentées dans un
état qui reste un état extrêmement
centralisé l'histoire française est une
histoire centralisée c'est pas un état
fédéral d'état français et nokia besoin
de représentation de ces territoires et
de leurs réalités locales et donc on va
regarder c'est pas une question
simplement d'implication dans le
territoire je pense qu'on peut très bien
être élu national et percevoir la
réalité d'un territoire sans être élu
local
mais ce lien avait une utilité en tout
cas pour une part dans les assemblées
donc vous prévoyez plutôt une forme
d'exception plutôt pour les petites
villes non mais on prévoit rien
simplement pause
on est à un moment de débat national le
président de la république est présent
de la république dans la république l'a
évoqué le premier ministre a évoqué
aussi on prévoit rien il faut que le
débat se nouent et c'est bien dans un
moment où on dit qu'on a des sujets qui
doivent pas porter de tabou qu'on puisse
le poser sur la table
tranquillement il n'y a pas l'y a pas de
polémique à voix faut juste se poser des
questions et dans le moment qu'on vit se
poser des questions c'est une bonne
chose pensez vous du fait qu'il ya de
nombreux sénateurs et ce qu'ils disent
soit on revient complètement sur le non
cumul et tout le monde prêts cumulés
soit on reste bien moi je pense qu'il ya
un chemin entre les deux oui et qu' il
n'est pas illogique que nous posions la
question disant voilà ce que ça a
apporté de positif la fin du cumul
et voilà peut-être les écueils il ya
peut-être d'autres solutions que ça
d'ailleurs qu'on a rencontrés au moment
où on voit comment ça se met en oeuvre
depuis 24 mois je pense que la question
n'est pas de revenir toujours en arrière
et de rld et faire ce que d'autres ont
fait mais peut-être en continue
d'évaluer et d'évoluer est-ce qu'en ce
moment très sensible du grand débat
après la crise des gilets jaunes qui est
encore là est ce que vraiment il faut
rouvrir le débat du non cumul on sait
qu'on est à la question pour les
citoyens d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le
cumul qui est impopulaire
vous demanderez à des gens qui vivent
dans les territoires ruraux finalement
la figure du député maire ou du maire
adjoint député n'était pas une sorte
d'élite si le cumul des indemnités pour
la voyez comprenez bien le sujet donc il
faut distinguer la question du cumul au
sens de le fait qu'on puisse être élu
local élu national et responsabilités
locales à la personne retrouvée mais
sans mais je pense qu'il faut et je
préfère or rien je pose sur la table le
débat parce que je pense qu'il faut le
faire avec cette tranquillité là sans
rentrer dans la caricature et de ya la
question du cumul des indemnités par
dessus mais distinguons les deux on peut
très bien
très drastiquement limiter le cumul des
indemnités est par ailleurs se dire que
c'est bien que des gens soient en
situation de responsabilité locale
les deux peuvent se combiner merci
beaucoup marc chesneau pour avoir
répondu à mes questions le débat est
donc ouvert et un débat ouvert sur la
question du non cumul et d'éventuelles
dérogations
merci à vous pour cette réaction martin
décidera qu'est ce que c'est opportun
justement tam tranier le rappeler en
plein mouvement des gilet jaune de
rouvrir cette thématique du non cumul
des mandats alors je ne sais pas si
c'est opportun ou pas en tout cas c'est
une question qui se pose
vous savez bien que dans beaucoup de nos
territoires des cahiers dit de doléances
sont ouverts par les parlers par les
élus par les maires et on voit que c'est
un sujet effectivement le cumul des
mandats qui revient parfois je ne dirais
pas de façon forcément prégnant mais qui
revient donc c'est une question
effectivement à laquelle il ne faut pas
se refuser de répondre
j'observe au sérieux à l'oral vous
justement à proposer la possibilité d'un
cumul pour les maires des communes par
exemple avec ces seuils de 2500
habitants eh oui alors je ne sais pas
quel et les noms seuil et je crois que
ça a été bien exprimée par marc raynaud
je ne sais pas s'il ya véritablement un
bon soyons un mauvais seuil il a très
bien fait le distinguo entre cumul
d'indemnités et cumul de mandat qui est
un vrai sujet et je partage ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est que on confond parfois
un petit peu les deux donc je pense que
il est important notamment nous les
sénateurs nous sommes parfaitement au
nom riz de cela de nos territoires il
est important que nous ayons un ancrage
local et de proximité
donc de ce point de vue je trouve que
c'est dommage que beaucoup d'entre nous
ait été obligé de démissionner d'un
mandat exécutif
cela ne nous empêche pas bien évidemment
de rester conseiller de rester quand
même dans nos territoires mais je crois
qu'ils vous l'avez un décor cela vaut
mais pas de la même manière puisque
aujourd'hui vous savez bien qu'on ne
peut pas cumuler deux exécutifs
or il est souvent important de savoir un
petit peu de quelle manière va
s'exprimer en réalité cette proximité de
quelle manière un élu quand il émet ou
quand il est conseiller municipal va
pouvoir porter un certain nombre de
sujets de son territoire
donc je crois qu'il ne faut pas
s'interdire ce débat là il faut bien
faire le distinguo entre bien évidemment
ce qui concerne les indemnités de ce qui
concerne
véritablement les engage à vous en tant
que parlementaire vous le faites mais
chez les français c'est peut-être plus
compliqué justement je crois que nous
avons images de ce qu'on appelait les
cumuls et rend le temps fois oui moi je
crois que en fait la vraie question qui
se pose à nous sait qui fait quoi et
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne savent
pas en réalité ce que font leurs élus
parfois ils connaissent parfaitement les
actions de leurs mères de leurs élus
locaux
parce que ce sont les zélés de proximité
en revanche dès lors que vous vous
éloignez un tout petit peu de cette
proximité la même vis-à-vis du
département moi je rencontre des des
administrés des concitoyens qui ne
savent pas forcément qui fait quoi
je ne vous parle pas des parlementaires
et donc il ya une espèce de je pense de
confusion dans l'esprit de beaucoup de
nos concitoyens et le grand débat à cela
j'ai envie de dire comme peut-être en
tout cas je l'espère et je l'appelle de
tous mes voeux de nous permettre à un
moment donné d' expliquer très
clairement qu'il avait déserté ce grand
débat martens existe certaines vertus il
a certaines vertus
je ne suis pas une grande fan où je vais
tout à fait franche avec vous mais les
choses sont posés à table là où j'estime
que c'est un tout petit peu enfin ça
pose question c'est que ça va dans
beaucoup de directions toutes très
différentes mais sur le fond ça permet
en même temps nous mêmes les élus et les
parlementaires de nous interroger sur
nos propres manières de fonctionner et
de partager ce que nous sommes censés
porter entre actualité qui touche de
près le sénat ce sont les nouvelles
révélations au martinez et drake de
mediapart assure alexandre benalla
jean-pierre seraient les co rapporteurs
de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire est d'ailleurs à vos côtés
est en train de nuit jean pierre sueur à
quelle est votre réaction à ces
dernières révélations de mediapart on
découvre notamment et bien qu alexandre
benalla était peut-être la cheville
ouvrière de contrat avec un oligarque
russe alors qu'il travaillait encore à
l'elysée qu'il a vu vincent kraz le 26
juillet en violation de son contrôle
judiciaire et qu'il y avait des liens
très forts qui sont restés avec l'elysée
après sa mise en examen
vous savez à succès comme nous à
l'audition publique qui a eu lieu lundi
dernier
au cours de laquelle monsieur benalla a
déclaré n'avoir pas eu d'activité de ce
type pendant qu'il était à l'elysée
autres addictions tonnelle non sur base
a dit que s'il avait créé une nouvelle
société eux c'était une coïncidence et
qu'il n'y avait pas de relation non par
jura rapport à mes lèvres prend
connaissance comme tous mes collègues de
ce que publie aujourd'hui médiapart de
ce que publie le monde et je rappelle
simplement qu'il y à une loi et que
cette loi prévoit des sanctions très
lourdes lorsque l'on ment sous serment
jusqu'à deux ans de prison lorsque l'on
ment sous serment ça peut être cinq ans
de prison cinq ans de prison et une
somme importante 75000 euros d'amendé
lorsque l'on ment sous serment
nous avons publié notre rapport dans
quelques temps et bien entendu nous
sommes extrêmement attentifs à tout ce
qui est dit et à tout ce qui est induit
par ce qui est 10e et qui aujourd'hui
paraît eux dans mediapart et dans le
monde entier vous pourriez saisir la
justice vous avertis c'est fort de cela
étant nous prendrons les décisions que
la commission des lois décidera de
prendre et nous ferons des propositions
mais s'il est certain que cette affaire
est grave
nul ne peut le contester aujourd'hui
cette affaire est très grave et d'autre
part chacun a pu entendre des auditions
publiques
c'est important pour nous de faire des
auditions publiques
car il doit y avoir une transparence et
bien merci beaucoup d'anciens sert
d'abord répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup tam pour cette réaction
je vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter une
partie un de ces enregistrements révélés
par mediapart il ya quelques minutes à
présent c'est un film c'est une bonne
défense de 26 ans je vis a pas grand
monde qui provoque des commissions d
enquête parlementaire qui bloque le
fonctionnement du parlement
serena qui plus est c'est ma vie et mort
2eme et nerveusement mais elle demeure
le seul choc celle-ci on est bien
entouré d'une bande débit d'ici demain
est vraiment une crise caisse comment ça
va se passer quoi l'islam a dit écoute
si demain il ya vraiment un truc pour
plus grave est question à ceux voulant
réagir comment tout ce que vous entendez
alexandre ménard martin décidera que sur
ces enregistrements et qui se vante
d'avoir provoqué deux commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires d'avoir bloqué
le parlement comment réagissez vous
alors écoutez sur la personne
d'alexandre benalla je ne me fais pas
trop d'illusions si vous voulez je vois
là une péripétie un nouvel épisode qui
s'ouvre moi je fais totalement confiance
à notre commission denquête pour mener
jusqu'au bout
voir s'il ya eu par jure pas afin de
voir quels éventuellement suites seront
données à toutes ces nouvelles
révélations qu'il faudra vérifier bien
évidemment en revanche ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup plus c'est que ça révèle
quelque chose de notre de notre
gouvernance plus haut de l'état et ça
pour le coup vous voyez ça ne me réjouit
pas beaucoup non pas que la ferme et
nahla me réjouisse énormément mais je
pense que là c'est ça révèle énormément
sur un mode de fonctionnement sûr
peut-être des amitiés sur peut-être des
protections qui s'exerce je dis tout
cela au conditionnel il faut il faut
laisser le tout cela se déroulait le
plus sereinement possible si cela est
toujours possible mais là encore je
crois que si cela s'avérait être vrai il
faudra se poser la question de
latitude aux plus hautes au plus haut de
nos instances un haut niveau de l'elysée
vis-à-vis aussi du parlement c'est
justement l'objectif de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur les
dysfonctionnements à la tête de l'elysée
votre collègue françois grosdidier qui
est membre de cette commission denquête
était au micro de tam traduit on écoute
ses réactions tout de suite
françois grosdidier je voudrais votre
réaction est bien aux dernières
révélations de mediapart notamment sur
le fait que alexandra benalla était
impliqué selon mediapart dans les
contrats avec l'oligarque russe alors
même qu'il travaillait à l'elysée ça
c'est un mensonge de plus devant notre
commission puisqu'ils avaient juré le
contraire
ce qui est intéressant dans les
révélations de médiapart c'est que ça
confirme le lien entre benalla et le
président de la république et même on a
l'impression que ce sont deux
adolescents important avec l'elysée qui
ont été maintenus alors même qu'il était
le meilleur tu va les bouffer on avec le
président la république et avec monsieur
benalla en fait deux adolescents qui
sont dans un sentiment de surpuissance
nos limites et et qui défie le monde
entier et qui s'affranchissent de toute
règle et singulièrement d'état de droit
c'est exactement ce que nous avons c'est
ce que nous sentions dès le départ et en
a la confirmation comme on à l'interview
de monsieur cra dans charlie hebdo qui
révèle que c'était bien monsieur benalla
le patron de la sécurité dizaine
contrairement à tout ce qui a été
affirmé par les responsables de l'elysée
donc effectivement les intuitions de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale et et
elle est bonne elle est à dire l se
fonder sur des faits sur la déclaration
des syndicats de policiers sur les
éléments matériels comme l'arrêté du
préfet de police
et on a la confirmation et ça va
certainement continuer la presse révèle
toujours des nouveaux éléments qui
confirment que l'elysée a menti alors
serait tellement plus simple de dire que
ça avait dysfonctionné impôts des
panneaux avec le staff de campagne et
s'occuper de la sécurité présidentielle
et que serviteur cadré depuis la
commission d enquête parlementaire que
peut-elle faire face à sale et mensonges
en qu'installe deux peuples est
impuissante aujourd'hui elle est
impuissante son travail c'est d'établir
la vérité dans qu'elle établit sa vérité
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale
compte amasser de l'assemblée aura fait
la lumière
sur les événements après aux français
d'en tirer des conclusions et à la
justice qui sera certainement saisi pour
et bien jugé de tous les cas de parjure
devant la commission denquête merci
beaucoup françois grosdidier d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
voilà pour cette réaction enregistré il
ya quelques instants l'autre actualité
du cnrc l'examen de la loi pacte martha
de cidre etc on sait que la droite
sénatoriale s'est opposé la
privatisation notamment d'aéroports de
paris est ce que ce n'est pas
contradictoire avec la doctrine
finalement propres aux républicains un
peu plus libérale sur ces questions
alors je crois qu'à travers le dossier
adp de toute façon laissons se dérouler
l'examen du texte de loi mais à travers
donc le sujet de la priver des
privatisations pardon adp se pose la
question si la souverainté à un moment
donné vous avez vu aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs au kg il ya une question qui
a porté sur l'aéroport de toulouse vous
comprenez bien toutes les interrogations
qui peuvent se présenter à nous pour
pour essayer de comprendre et de voir
quelles sont réellement les les attendus
et les objectifs de notre exécutif
aujourd'hui autour de cela dans le doute
compte tenu de ce que nous avons vécu
par le passé
il me semble prudent personnellement moi
je suis contre la privatisation d'un des
pays les vrais je suis l air nous sommes
un certain nombre parce que se posent à
nous comme je voulais dire une question
de souverainté aussi c'est quelque chose
qui est très important pour beaucoup de
raisons et économique bien sûr mais
aussi de véritablement de capacité et de
hub en fait en europe sur lesquelles il
faut que l'état puisse avoir la main eh
bien merci beaucoup à martin et senna
bastien notre invité d'ailleurs et bruno
le maire à la mise et l'économie a été
interrogé sur ce point par thème traduit
je vous propose de l'écouter
bruno le maire mardi en discussion
générale vous espériez avoir des
discussions constructives avec les sénat
les avez vous eu sur les seuils relevés
par le sénat contre votre avis et quand
vous voyez l'opposition d'une bonne
partie des sénateurs droite comprise aux
privatisations
il ya eu des points positifs sur les
seuils il ya eu des améliorations côté
apporté d'autres avec lesquels je suis
en complet désaccord je pense que
relever le seuil de 50 à 100
la représentation du personnel il faut
bien voir ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que les entreprises entre 50 et 100
salariés qui avaient un comité
représentant le personnel toute une
organisation pour les syndicats n'en
n'aurai plus moi je ne suis pas
favorable du tout à cela je pense qu'on
a besoin de dialogue social dans
l'entreprise et je ne crois absolument
pas opportun de relever le seuil de
représentativité de 50 à 100 salariés et
sur les privatisations comment
jugez-vous l'opposition de la droite et
elle est contradictoire avec les valeurs
de votre ancienne famille politique pour
vous nous verrons quelle sera l'issue
des discussions
ce que je veux dire simplement c'est que
je me souviens d'un ancien candidat à la
primaire de la droite qui avait gagné
ces primaires qui disait qu'il voulait
engager des privatisations qu'il fallait
que l'état cède ses participations dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises pour
investir c'est exactement ce que nous
voulons faire et j'espère que les
républicains seront retrouvées ce qui
est leur cohérence idéologique pour
améliorer nos propositions se cessions
d'actifs
je suis tout à fait prêt et jean
françois husson le rapporteur a fait des
propositions très intéressantes en ce
sens là à renforcer les garanties sur
les privatisations
nous nous voulons des privatisations qui
soit sûre pour nos compatriotes qui leur
donne des garanties sur les tarifs sur
les redevances et puis je rappelle que
rien ne changera notamment pour adp sur
le contrôle des frontières et sur les
aspects de sécurité mais j'espère que
les républicains avec le rapporteur jean
françois husson resteront cet esprit
constructif pour améliorer nos
propositions et pas pour les détruire
attendait ce qui en dit on vend les
bijoux de famille et qui avait une
position très ferme
c'est une question politique pour vous
nous verrons je veux pas préjuger ce que
sera le débat la seule chose dont je
suis convaincu c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
rôle de l'état ce n'est pas de gérer des
entreprises qui appartiennent au secteur
concurrentiel
parce que adp n'est pas un monopole je
rappelle qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
possibilités pour les voyageurs ils
passent par passer par le round ils
peuvent passer par francfort peut
s'arrêter dans des aéroports de province
donc ce n'est pas un monopole le
contrôle des frontières restent
strictement du domaine de l'état et la
souveraineté de l'état et l'argent que
nous allons récupérer va servir à
investir dans l'avenir des français dans
les technologies de rupture tout cela ne
devrait poser aucun problème de
fonds aux républicains et j'espère
qu'ils reviendront de ce point de vue là
à la sagesse alors hier le sénat
également bruno le maire a repoussé d'un
an
l'interdiction de certains ustensiles en
plastique à usage unique revenant sur
des dispositions votées avec la loi sur
l'alimentation est ce une mesure à
laquelle vous êtes favoris parce que
cela va rester à l'assemblée nationale
pour lui moi je le souhaite puisque les
dispositions qui avait été voté
l'assemblée nationale avait été voté
contre l'avis du gouvernement et je
pense qu'il est très important de
trouver un bon équilibre entre la
transition énergétique la transition
économique pour protéger notre planète
tout le monde évidemment veut avancer
dans ce sens là et aussi la sauvegarde
est aussi la sauvegarde parce que
j'estime est pas une question de recul
ou d'avancé simple à ce qu on veut
garder nos emplois et avoir des
transitions qui se fasse dans un temps
raisonnable
on voit bien que lorsqu'on va trop vite
qu'on veut accélérer les transformations
de manière trop précipitée
ça provoque des blocages donc je préfère
qu'on fasse ça un bon rythme pour que
les entreprises puissent s'adapter
plutôt que de détruire des emplois
brutalement parce que derrière il ya des
emplois il ya des entreprises
il y a des usines donnons-nous un peu
plus de temps c'est ce qu' il y a été
adopté au sénat pour que la
transformation se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions sans menacer l'emploi
merci beaucoup bruno l'air
d'impressionner à mes questions cet
après midi de l'avoir suivi
[Musique]